[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
johnny depp versus amber heard week
three in highlights suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent depp
finishes testimony with a strong
statement and what led up to this unique
testimony you brought muffins you said
from your husband right you get and you
gave those to ms heard correct
may i clarify what occurred so that we
can stop talking about the muffin plus
in cases like this there is nothing
anybody can do they have the sole right
to
make the judgment whether they can
continue to employ somebody or not depp
and heard's former agent testifies over
the washington post article's impact and
later a look inside depp's relationship
with drugs and alcohol i think jack
sparrow is more drunk than johnny depp
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily i'm
your host brian buckman we're taking a
closer look at the highlights of week
three in the johnny depp amber heard
defamation suit the lawsuit stems from a
2018 washington post op-ed written by
herd where she describes herself as a
victim of domestic violence while depp
was never mentioned in the article he
argues readers knew he was publicly
linked to her
depp says he lost roles in both the
harry potter and pirates of the
caribbean franchises as a result of the
allegations after depp filed a 50
million dollar lawsuit against his
ex-wife heard shot back with a hundred
million dollar suit doubling down on her
domestic violence claims hurt is
expected to take the stand sometime next
week this comes after four days of
testimony from depp spilling into this
week while on the stand depp told jurors
when he learned he would not be rehired
for pirates of the caribbean six and how
that loss affected him
when did you first learn that disney was
not going to recast you in the pirates
franchise
it was
a probably two or three days after
this op-ed appeared captain jack sparrow
was a character that i had
built from the ground up
and
with something that i
i
[Music]
i
of course put a lot of
my as you do with all characters but you
put a lot of yourself
into the characters so
and
also
[Music]
having
worked on
these films with these people and
having added
much of myself much of my own
rewriting of the dialogue and
scenes and the jokes and whatever they
are
i didn't quite understand
how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney
um
that
they
would
but suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent
depp's attorneys ended redirect by
playing an audio recording of a fight
between depp and heard after that depp
made a powerful statement on domestic
abuse
last time that it got crazy between us i
really did think i was gonna lose my
life and i thought you would do it on
accident
and i told you that
i said oh my god i thought the first
time but i lost a
finger man come on
[Music]
i had a
a mineral can't exercise mineral spirits
thrown on my nose
i you can please tell people that it was
a fair fight and see what the see what
the jury and judge think tell the world
johnny tell them johnny depp i joined up
man i i'm a victim too domestic violence
and i know it's a fair fight it seems
how
what did you say in response when miss
heard said tell the world johnny tell
them johnny depp i johnny depp a man
i'm a victim too of domestic violence
i said yes
i am
i have nothing further your honor
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl and co-host terry austin dina i
don't think you could end a direct
examination of your star witness better
than what we just saw there from johnny
depp and the question is um how do you
think that's going to impact the jury in
this case as a whole
well those kind of recordings are
actually very persuasive we call them
contempt you know uh statements that you
make at the time actually carry greater
weight with rules such as hearsay
because if the idea is that you're not
strategically lying so for him having
said that at the time for her having
asked that question at the time is quite
important but in terms of the defamation
case does it matter if he is also a
victim of domestic violence probably not
his case is just saying that he never
abused her because if he ever did then
her statement was true so although i
think that is important
it's not everything that he needed to
prove yeah now terry the uk libel case
has given us somewhat of a preview for
what herd will likely say that she was
abused and was just able to hide it so
that no one can see how will that line
up with the testimony we've seen so far
well i think the testimony we've seen so
far is from all of the personnel around
depth and every one of them have said
they haven't seen any injuries on herd
but they've seen injuries on death and
we've heard from his security team and
they've confirmed that that they have
never seen any hurt now she's going to
spit it she might have covered it up
with me
but you have to think you you have to
believe that she's going to have to have
other people on her side confirm what
she has to say about the makeup so we'll
see what happens yeah i'd expect her to
testify maybe someone's uh psychological
background and talk about what she's
going through but also probably an
outcry witness someone that she spoke to
short in time to these alleged events
but of course you've got to stick with
us and we'll give you those updates as
they come in still ahead on law and
crime daily there's more coverage of the
johnny depp amber her defamation suit
before they come back what a forensic
psychologist diagnose amber hernia and
why her attorneys questioned the doctor
over muffins
[Music]
welcome back continue our recap of the
week in johnny depp amber heard
defamation trial in virginia on tuesday
a psychologist hired by deb's defense
team was called to the stand she
testified that herd has two personality
disorders on cross-examination things
got heated over confidentiality
you didn't disclose that you had met
with mr dapp mr waldman mr chu and ms
vasquez at mr depp's house for three to
four hours and had dinner and drinks
correct i did not disclose that it's not
significant to the report i justified it
in this case actually i sought
consultation about it this is a very
visible case it's been going on a very
long time and i understood that there
would be a need to
interview me and determine make an
informed decision about my
qualifications you were in fact so
excited about being involved in this
case that you told your husband that you
were going to be conducting the
examination of ms heard that is not
accurate the question that was asked was
because you brought muffins you said
from your husband right you get and you
gave those to ms heard correct
may i clarify what occurred so that we
can stop talking about the muffins
what happened was that
i was getting ready that morning i
frequently bring muffins to the office
my husband did happen to know that there
was going to be a celebrity client
coming in i asked him to go to the
bakery near our house and pick up the
muffins for me because i was running
late he brought the muffins back to the
house i brought them into the office
ms heard and i enjoyed the muffins
together i think i made a comment to her
along the lines like my husband got
these for us today meaning he purchased
the muffins we are now enjoying them
because of him
muffins we we talk about muffins in this
case well anyways terry what were some
of the highlights overall if muffins are
one of them that's fine uh but overall
to dr curry's testimony that worked in
depth's favor
well dr curry was wonderful and her
explanation as far as the muffins were
concerned definitely made her credible
and likable she was smart she was
credible she is a clinical and forensic
psychologist and she is objective she
performed a number of tests the
minnesota personality test which has 567
questions that's a lot of questions and
she made sure that she told what her
diagnosis was and the symptoms that she
exhibited as far as death was concerned
is that she had the borderline pernality
disorder and the histronics personality
disorder she made very clear there was
no ptsd so i think she was wonderful she
made her points and i think that the
jury really liked who she was and
listened to what she had to say yeah now
dina were herds lawyers able to damage
the credibility or findings of curry of
dr curry's results and what what's the
doctor's testimony going to do for her
when she goes up and testifies
it's a typical strategy of trying to say
that there's some sort of bias because
they are getting paid by the team that
they're testifying for so that is fairly
typical this idea of the muffins i mean
we saw that with so many of the
witnesses for johnny depp the ones that
were employed by him amber hurts
attorneys really trying to say that that
was why that they were testifying in his
favor it is clear it came across that
they all did like him he seems to be a
boss that his employees like
but there's a far stretch to say
somebody likes the person they're
working for and that they're gonna lie
for them under oath i don't think that
they showed that she was taking her bias
that far absolutely well we'll see how
that bias or those implications continue
as the case progresses coming up on law
and crime daily we're on to day 10 of
johnny depp versus amber hurt
a talent manager points her finger at
her abuse allegations hear his video
deposition after this
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
the defamation trial of johnny depp
versus amber hurd the jury so far has
heard from some of depp's closest
acquaintances on wednesday his former
agent testified via video deposition
telling jurors of how amber's
allegations affected depp's career
in cases like this there is nothing
anybody can do it is the
directive of the studio to and they have
the sole right to
make the judgment whether they can
continue to employ somebody or not do
you believe that mr depp
is still a shard of mystery not visible
to the public
no
and when did that
change i don't know exactly when
would you say it was cumulative over the
period of time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
[Music]
his off-screen
reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by that
i mean the things that she's accused
johnny of doing
both
in
that had been made public
terry is this the case right here
damages to depp's career or uh does it
sorry the depths attorney have to prove
more to show that he was harmed by this
op-ed
well i think that carina was excellent
for the defamation damages claim they
can show more but he made a direct
connection between that article and the
lost opportunities he specifically said
that depp did not get pirate six and he
talked about conversations with the
studios and with the executives and he
basically said that jerry buckheimer of
disney and others said look we're not
going to go forward and he
tied it directly to what was going on at
the op-ed and the timing was perfect so
i think this was excellent he could get
more i think as far as other witnesses
talking about the connection but i think
carino did it yeah dina how does this
work with herd's case depp has to prove
that she was lying but what does she
have to prove to win her counter claim
well she essentially has to prove the
same things that he has to prove because
it's a counter defamation claim so she's
saying that statements that he and it's
actually his lawyer said regarding that
her um
accusations were a hoax he has to you
know show that that she has to show that
that defamed her and his defense will be
that it's true and so a lot of the
evidence that came out even now about
you know him her hitting his finger you
know that goes also to his defense of
her counter claim and then also she's
going to have to show that she was
damaged and didn't get movies etc as a
result of his claims yeah the damage
part for her is going to be interesting
to see but of course she's going to take
the stand herself when we come back
we're zeroing in on day 11 of testimony
in johnny depp versus amber heard our
analysts break down the most important
testimony from all three witnesses of
the day
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
continue our coverage now in the johnny
depp versus amber heard defamation suit
on thursday jurors heard from the aclu's
general counsel he testified prior
versions of the washington post op-ed
called depp out by name
this is an article
that
[Music]
was in u.s today
and
[Music]
specifically ties
amber statements in her op-ed piece to
johnny depp
and when jessica white says
so much
for not mentioning jd
what did she mean
i speculate that she was
saying that um
there were significant efforts made by
amber's attorneys to take out the
references
to
johnny depp in her marriage um
and
yet nonetheless
people made that connection
and in particular the
reporter for the usa today
took her
to be referring to johnny depp when she
spoke of being the victim of domestic
violence correct correct
because that was consistent with your
understanding she was referring at least
in part to johnny depp correct
yeah based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that there were that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage
jurors also heard from malcolm conley
who worked security for depp he
testified about injuries on depth's face
and later what happened after the
infamous fight in australia
on the left-hand side under his eye
there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the left
hand side of his nose and under his left
eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do
he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
and how did miss heard seem to you when
you saw her uh on that day when you
arrived to extract him
crazy
crazy
crazy
fierce you know fierce
okay
what was the uh what was the last thing
miss heard said as you were taking mr
jeff out of the house to to go to your
apartment and then the hospital
yeah
the last one what i recall hearing is as
i'm getting johnny out is yeah just off
of your guys you're covered like you
always do
after that jurors heard from starlin
jenkins another member of deaf security
team he testified about the quote
surprise heard left in the boss's bed
before leaving for the coachella music
festival
what was your job that weekend
provide security and transportation
animal care
amber's rolling assistant take care of
her whatever she needed while she was
there at the parker or didn't uh out
shop
and did you have any discussions with ms
hurd on the way to coachella that
evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
what about the rest of that weekend mr
jenkins any injuries that you saw
no injuries
um
have you ever witnessed any physical
abuse between mr depp and miss heard
no
i know that's an interesting practical
joke dina what does the timing and the
behind the scenes commentary of the
op-ed say to you about her's motivations
for releasing this article
i mean the timing of it being released
so close to aquaman you could see it as
either a she wanted to help raise
awareness of the cause and tied her to
her movie or as johnny depp's team is
trying to say she was using it for her
own personal gain i mean they've said
that was why she made the allegation to
begin with back in 2016 was in order to
extract more money from him for the
divorce and then again this article was
meant to kind of hype the publicity of
her movie paint her in a better light
essentially yeah i think the article
came out on the 18th of december and the
aquaman big marvel and dc fan myself i
think came out on the 21st so very close
in time uh terry at some point heard has
to answer to the many if not all of
these accusations is there a response
that would give her a chance to win this
trial
i think what herd is going to try to say
is one depth is a drug addict she's
going to try to say that he is an
alcoholic she's going to try to say that
he has an anger management issue and so
she's going to portray him as someone
who is uncontrolled and someone who
could definitely be violent not just
against cabinets not just against
physical property but against her as
well and because no one has seen what
has occurred behind closed doors she
might just be able to say look you
weren't there you didn't know i had to
deal with him 24 7. and this is what i
had to deal with i think the problem
will be no one has seen any injuries
we'll have to see whether or not her
witnesses are going to support her yeah
so we're interested to see how that
plays out thank you both for the
commentary and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you